und der erste Schritt nach dieser
Regierungserklärung ist der
Oppositionschef Friedrich Merzig sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren angesichts des
russischen Angriffskrieges gegen die
Ukraine und der folgen die dieser Krieg
mittlerweile auch für unser Land hat
steht die Europäische Union in diesen
Wochen und Monaten möglicherweise vor
der größten Bewährungsprobe ihrer
Geschichte
wir können daher alle nur hoffen dass
die 27 Staats- und Regierungschefs heute
und morgen in Brüssel zu guten und
tragfähigen Lösungen kommen Herr
Bundeskanzler wir wünschen Ihnen und
Ihren amtskolleginnen und Amtskollegen
in der Europäischen Union bei den
anstehenden Beratungen jeden möglichen
Erfolg
europa braucht diesen Erfolg
unser Land deutschland braucht diesen
Erfolg vor allem aber die Menschen die
privaten Haushalte und die vielen
Unternehmen die kleinen die mittleren
und die großen brauchen jetzt schnelle
und wirksame Hilfe
es sollte dabei auch klar sein welche
Aufgaben die Europäische Union übernimmt
was sie leisten kann und muss was Europa
jetzt ausdrücklich nicht tun sollte und
was zwingend in der Verantwortung und
der Zuständigkeit der Mitgliedstaaten
bleiben muss
lassen Sie mich dazu etwas ausführlicher
sprechen meine Damen und Herren die
notwendigen Sanktionen gegen Russland
und sie haben Bundeskanzler darüber
ausführlich gesprochen gehen nur
gemeinsam und die hat Europa in der Tat
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten eine
große Geschlossenheit und eine große
Entschlossenheit gezeigt Europa hat
diese Bewährungsprobe bestanden auch in
enger Abstimmung und Kooperation mit
anderen vor allem mit den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika
auch die finanziellen und humanitären
Hilfen für die Ukraine den weitgehend
jedenfalls nur gemeinsam auch hier hat
die Europäische Union wirkungsvoll und
zielführend geholfen
es wäre schließlich wünschenswert
gewesen meine Damen und Herren wenn auch
die militärische Hilfe für die
Europäische Union
europäisch abgestimmt und koordiniert
vorgenommen worden wäre und ich
wiederhole von dieser Stelle aus zum
wiederholten Male wir hätten es für
richtig gehalten wenn die Ukraine wenn
die ukrainische Armee auch mit
Schützenpanzern und Kampfpanzern
westlicher Bauart ausgestattet worden
wäre abgestimmt in der Europäischen
Union so wie viele Mitgliedstaaten es
befürworten
so wie eine große Zahl von Kolleginnen
und Kollegen insbesondere aus der grünen
Fraktion und aus der FDP-Fraktion ist
befürworten so wie wir es befürworten
dieser Krieg wäre dann möglicherweise
schneller zu Ende gewesen
und nun zu den Energiepreisen Herr
Bundeskanzler aus ihrer
Regierungserklärung können die zuhören
und Zuhörer heute morgen die Betroffenen
privaten Haushalte die Unternehmen in
Deutschland und darüber hinaus kaum
etwas Konkretes entnehmen wann ihnen
denn nun endlich geholfen wird
sie haben auch wenig und gar nichts
gesagt zum Arbeitsprogramm der
Kommission das gestern vorgelegt worden
ist meine Damen und Herren bei diesem
Arbeitsprogramm muss man den Eindruck
gewinnen als ob bis auf eine einzige
Ausnahme und das ist die sogenannte
Chemikalien Rechtsprechung oder
rechtssitzung bis auf eine Ausnahme in
allen anderen Bereichen in dieser
Europäischen Kommission der Apparat
weiter läuft und läuft und läuft und
jede Woche und jeden Monat neue
Richtlinien neue Verordnungen neue
Belastungen vor allem für die
Unternehmen in Europa auslöst meine
Damen und Herren das ist nein wir haben
Ihnen den konkreten Vorschlag gemacht
und sie haben es ja aufgenommen für das
nationale Programm ein
belastungsmoratorium warum sprechen Sie
nicht auch über ein belastungsmoratorium
jetzt in der Europäischen Union
warum lassen sie zu warum befördert ihre
Regierung dass auch in der Europäischen
Kommission von Woche zu Woche weitere
Vorschläge und Belastungen für die
Unternehmen gemacht werden bis hin zu
einer
csr-richtlinie die die Berichtspflichten
der Unternehmen gerade jetzt in dieser
Krise endgültig zu einem bürokratischen
Monstrum werden lassen wir brauchen
jetzt ein belastungsmoratorium für die
Unternehmen in der Europäischen Union
und damit auch in Deutschland
und dann bleiben tatsächlich zahlreiche
Aufgaben in der nationalen Verantwortung
meine Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler
sie fahren in dieser Hinsicht morgen
heute und morgen nach Brüssel nicht
gerade mit gutem Vorbild im Gegenteil
Deutschland dürfte in Brüssel bewertet
werden als das Land in Europa dessen
Regierung in den letzten Monaten am
heftigsten gestritten und mit am
wenigsten erreicht hat bei der
Entlastung der privaten Haushalte und
der Unternehmen
dauert in wenigen Tagen jetzt acht
Monate und wenn man hört was sie auch
auf verbandstagungen gerade vor wenigen
Tagen hier in Berlin gesagt haben dann
wissen Sie ja schon sehr viel länger
welche Folgen dieser Krieg
möglicherweise haben kann sie haben hier
in Berlin vor wenigen Tagen gesagt ich
war mir immer sicher dass er putin war
gemeint das tun würde nämlich Energie
als Waffe einzusetzen und dann sagen Sie
das war glaube ich zu einer Zeit als die
allermeisten das nicht für
wahrscheinlich gehalten haben aber ich
habe es für möglich gehalten sie nehmen
Bezug auf eine Besprechung mit
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern im
Bundeskanzleramt im dezember 2021 ich
war mir immer sicher dass er das tun
würde Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie sich
im dezember 2021 schon sicher waren dass
er das tun würde warum haben sie dann
eigentlich bis die Kriegsbeginn an
nordstream 2 festgehalten und das zu
einem privatwirtschaftlichen Projekt
erklärt und warum haben Sie eigentlich
von dieser klugen Erkenntnis nicht ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Europäischen Union in kenntnisgesetz
dass man schon im Dezember 2021 hätte an
Maßnahmen denken müssen zur Bewältigung
dieser Krise
sie haben zu Beginn sie haben zu Beginn
ihrer
Regierungserklärung klausewitz zitiert
Herr Bundeskanzler von Clausewitz stammt
auch der schöne Satz aus dem Wissen muss
ein können werden das hätten wir von
Ihnen auch erwartet
sie haben sie haben eine
gaskommission um Vorschläge gebeten zur
Dämpfung der Gaspreise und zur Lösung
dieses Problems diese Vorschläge liegen
nun seit Anfang der letzten Woche vor
wir haben zwei Sitzungswochen des
Deutschen Bundestages in dieser und in
der letzten sie haben nicht einen
einzigen Vorschlag unterbreitet heute
welche Schlussfolgerungen denn aus
dieser gaskommission gezogen werden
sollen zur Lösung des Problems bei der
Gasbeschaffung und bei den Gaspreisen
es bleibt es bleibt völlig offen was
denn diejenigen privaten Haushalte die
noch mit Öl heizen oder die zum Beispiel
gerade frisch angeschafft haben eine
Pelletheizung wie diese halt wie dieser
Haushalte denn konkret entlastet werden
sollen damit kein Missverständnis
entsteht wir befürworten hier
weitestgehend gemeinsame europäische
Wege aber es gibt Verantwortungen im
nationalen Zusammenhang der sie
nachkommen müssen und die die
Europäische Union überhaupt nicht
übernehmen kann diese Fragen gehören
dazu und diese Fragen bedürfen der
Beantwortung im Deutschen Bundestag und
nicht auf der Ebene des Europäischen
Rates
und wenn sie jetzt als einziges Datum
nennen wo die privaten Haushalte und die
Unternehmen Entlassung erwarten dürfen
das Frühjahr 2023 dann kann ich Ihnen
nur sagen der Bundeskanzler Winterreifen
muss man im Oktober aufziehen und nicht
erst im Frühjahr des nächsten Jahr
jetzt brauchen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in Deutschland eine klare
Perspektive jetzt brauchen die Menschen
und die Unternehmen in Deutschland eine
klare Antwort wann sie möglichst bald in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen mit
konkreter Entlastung rechnen dürfen und
deswegen will ich abschließend sagen die
besten Beschlüsse in Brüssel Reich
bewirken überhaupt nichts wenn die
Bundesregierung in Deutschland nicht
schnell zu wirksamen Entlastungen kommt
für private Haushalte und für die
Unternehmen von denen die meisten nicht
mehr lange Zeit haben herzlichen Dank
soweit also Friedrich Merz der am Anfang
seiner Rede konzertierte das Europa
gemeinsam die Sanktionen gegen Russland
durchgesetzt habe März kritisierte aber
bei der militärischen Hilfe des die
Union ist von Anfang an für richtig
gehalten hätte Schützenpanzer oder
Kampfpanzer ein zu setzen
bei den Energiepreisen kritisierte er
das hier den Menschen immer noch nicht
geholfen ist sie wissen nicht wo sie
dran sind und gegen Ende hatte er noch
mal betont es müsste jetzt Perspektiven
geben auch für die deutsche Wirtschaft
die durch europäische Regelung nicht
ständig mehr belastet werden